elle est décrite comme la novice la
touche humaine ou encore la femme qui
pilote une opération charme mais
derrière son sourire valérie plan
n'hésite pas à montrer ses dents
politique louise harel en sait quelque
chose
c'était la première à être battu par
valérie plante le 3 novembre 2013
elle remporte son premier pari elle est
élue conseillère de ville pourtant la
politique c'était tout neuf pour elle
elle a grandi à 600 km de montréal à
rouyn noranda une année pour parfaire
son anglais en ontario et la voici à
montréal en anthropologie en muséologie
et enfin en intervention multi ethnique
la fondation filles d'action qu'elle
dirige c'est sa porte sur le montréal du
terrain la mère de deux enfants est
aussi une sportive accomplie elle a
participé cet été au triathlon
international
et c'est au contact des électeurs
qu'elle dit sentir le vent tourner en sa
faveur quand elle cherche à succéder à
richard bergeron à la tête de projet
montréal
cris de victoire elle vient de battre
guillaume lavoie par quelques dizaines
de voix il reste alors quelques mois
avant de faire campagne pour la mairie
le plus grand défi c'est de se faire
connaître elle choisit de frapper les
esprits
elle attire surtout l'attention avec son
idée de ligne rose
si elle est élue elle sera la première
femme à la tête de la métropole
et alors elle pourrait arborer ce
t-shirt ici mathieu prost radio canada
montréal
[Musique]